mort par te prend l'air à la crise
sanitaire a obligé la ville de mort par
penser autrement son espace culturel
c'est donc une exposition hors les murs
qui prend place dans la ville il ya un
énorme besoin de relations sociales de
culture aujourd'hui bon bah nous sommes
allés vers vers les mort pas y ait en
espérant qu'il revienne vers nous très
vite au mot repartent évidemment c'est
le mort quasi un jean-pierre evrard qui
a été choisie par la commune pour être
l'invité d'honneur
il présente plusieurs portraits sur le
thème de la fête du vaudou est des
photos qui lui viennent de ses nombreux
voyages en afrique une fête célébrée
chaque année le 10 janvier au bénin leur
fait du vaudou est beaucoup plus récente
c'était un hommage à toutes ces
personnes qui ont disparu qui ont
souffert dans la traite des esclaves
donc c'est une connaissance de ce
festival est donc je suis allée une
première année puis jardin deuxième
n'est troisième année une quatrième
année et donc ça représente à milliers
de photos à peu près parmi elles 20
photos ont été sélectionnées pour
l'exposition mort par tu prends l'air
pour jean-pierre evrard ces photos
relève d'un travail d'artisan l'homme
qui est devant dans son laboratoire dans
sa chambre noire et qui qui travaillent
ceux qui manipulent ces photos on sent
beaucoup plus l'homme est pillée
athlètes à petit peu moins la machine
une exposition en libre accès organisée
au coeur de la ville un endroit
stratégique pour que le maximum de
personnes puissent s'y arrêter voilà un
mot repas est quand même une ville dite
dortoir à l'origine avec quelques
centres on a vraiment pris le
centre-ville mort par te prend l'air est
un avant-goût de la 36e édition du salon
mort parts qui devrait prendre place le
13 mars pour l'occasion de nouvelles
oeuvres seront exposées au centre albert
camus